SPEAKER: Hi!
Leah and Diana are here to talk
about Clowns Without Borders.
I'm sure you'll
find this discussion
of this wonderful
organization fascinating.
But first-- Yeah, I know.
How does he do it?
You're on.
Oh yeah take them off.
ALEX: Grazie!
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
Yay!
How do you say--
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - "ROW, ROW, ROW YOUR
BOAT"]
See?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ALEX: [SPEAKING ITALIAN] What?
Oh.
All right, our problem
[SPEAKING ITALIAN] Yeah!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Grazie!
Merci!
Donde, how you say-- if you
learn some English, yeah.
Yo like Alex the
jester on Facebook.
No, I don't speak English.
I'm here for Clowns
Without Borders.
What you saw, well we
just like to communicate
in that special clown way.
I don't mean birthday party
with balloons and big shoes.
Red noses are cool, though.
And I love to go out on a limb,
and just put the bar this high,
and make this client.
At another time, when
we have more time,
I will show you the secrets
of nonverbal communication.
Two horrible words.
I call it primal talk.
Primal talk is what
Clowns Without Borders
does what they go, as
I do, to countries all
of the world where this
is the way we have.
I think you can
see the feelings,
the emotions, the communication.
And the last little
thing I'm going to say,
as far as putting
the bar up here,
I claim that clowns can show
you physical communication that
can help you that
connect with people.
Well you guys all have
elite social skills,
but you might know
a colleague-- you
might know a colleague who
could use a little help.
Connecting faster, and
with Primal Talk all
I want to see if I can show
you is to connect quicker
with people, be more
empathetic, a better friend,
find love, and save the world.
That's about it.
I think on saving
the world, listen
to what Leah and Diana
have to say about Clowns
Without Borders.
DIANA Thank you.
Hi everyone.
I'm Diana.
I'm the vice president of
the board of Clowns Without
Borders, and the
former director.
We're a basically
volunteer run organization.
So we pay very little to
an administrative team
to keep us going, but
in the US here, we
are basically volunteer run.
And Leah is one of our
volunteers and performers.
And we want to explain what
Clowns Without Borders is,
and just raise awareness
about what clown is.
Because it's not, I don't
think, what you guys
are expecting from some
conversations we had earlier.
But we wanted to
bring Alex in just
because he would be fine little
bit of entertainment piece
that would be appropriate
for you guys at Google.
So we thought he was
going to be a little
nice piece of entertainment.
So Leah, take it away.
LEAH: Yeah.
So thank you, Alex.
So we're just going
to run through what
Clowns Without Borders does.
I'm comfortable
especially since it's not
the most biggest crowd
I've ever worked with.
If you guys have
questions in the middle,
you can feel free
to interrupt me.
I'm cool with that, or we can
ask afterwards, or whatever.
So we're Clowns Without
Borders, basically
no child without a
smile, that's our aim.
This is a picture
of what we're not.
So that's not us,
that's not Alex.
Maybe my grandfather's in there.
But no, he's not.
But to give you a better
idea of who we are is this.
And so we do wear make up
sometimes, and clown noses,
although not necessarily.
Or more kind of a
pedestrian sort of clown.
We find that sort
of more approachable
in the places that we go and
the people that we work with.
So this is another example more
the kind of clown that we are.
So here's just another picture.
This is basically a
better description
of what we look like.
So you can see we
still look funny,
but not like creepy funny.
Well.
I don't think any
of them are creepy.
Maybe like bordering.
It depends I guess what time
of day, or where they show up.
And here's just another
example of who we are.
So we work all over the world.
And this is the South Africa
Clowns Without Borders,
and Diana will interrupt
me if I get this wrong,
but we worked a lot as an
organization in South Africa
and then in South Africa,
they started their own Clowns
Without Borders.
And so this is them, I
think performing probably
at a school.
And basically what Clowns
Without Borders does
is we use simplicity,
surprise, and sanctuary.
So where was this taken?
DIANA: Sudan.
LEAH: This is in Sudan.
And now Diana is going
to talk a little bit just
about the history of
Clowns Without Borders,
and that kind of thing.
DIANA: So you've seen a
few photos which give you
a little bit of an
idea of what we do.
We mainly perform for children
living in crisis situations,
and then also their communities.
So it could be their families,
their caregivers, schools,
refugee camps.
We'll go into that a little
bit more in a minute.
It was actually
founded in Spain.
Now we're comprised
of nine, and counting,
organizations around the world.
So Spain is where
it started in 1993.
It was founded by a man by
the name of Tortell Poltrona.
And he ran the first non-animal
oriented circus in Spain.
And the first trip was to
a Croatian refugee camp,
and it literally started
with a caravan of vans.
They were invited in to come
into the refugee camp in 1993.
And they took a caravan
of vans from Barcelona,
and set up shop and performed
for thousands of people
at a time.
So the first performances
were actually like this one,
which you can see.
This is actually in Bhutan
but with thousands of kids,
like oceans of children.
And in 1996, Clowns
Without Borders
was founded by a man
named Moshe Cohen.
He lives out in San Francisco,
where clowns I think
are a little bit more accepted.
Maybe even here
on the east coast.
And now you can see
the list of countries.
And the list is growing.
We're starting up organizations
in Finland, Columbia,
Australia, Brazil,
the list goes on.
So our mission is twofold.
We first seek to improve
the psychological conditions
in crisis situations
bringing humor and laughter
through volunteers performances
as well as workshops
with children and educators.
And then we also strive
to raise awareness.
And so that's what
we're doing here today.
So we ask all of our volunteers
when they're not in the field,
because they might only be in
the field for one week or three
weeks of time
during the year, we
ask them to promote awareness
back in their home cities,
wherever it may be
around the world.
So my most recent trip
was actually to India.
And I thought it would
put this picture in.
We were actually working
on the construction sites
where all of the
tech buildings are
being built outside of Delhi.
Possibly a Google
office, I'm not sure.
But a lot of car
companies, cell phone
companies, and those
kinds of things.
And we did performances for
the construction workers
the migrant
construction workers,
and their families
who live there.
So there's these makeshift
schools that are set up,
and day cares that are set up
in and among the construction.
So you have a huge giant
building, 20 stories high,
and then a little tiny room
where these children are
educated while they
are living there.
So we would go in and we
would do performances there.
LEAH: So I think the
sort of main thing
if you want to just
some it up, what
we do is we promote
laughter, and we
try to bring levity and laughter
to places around the world
that we've been invited to.
So we usually go to
a place like we maybe
have a partnership with
a sister organization
or something like that, or we
see a need and we go and say
OK.
There's like maybe
a refugee camp,
or we've been to Haiti
after the earthquake,
and before the earthquake,
and that kind of thing.
And just try to bring
laughter and levity.
And I guess I personally think
that's really important just
because it's like
a way to connect.
And I know when
I'm feeling down,
if I could just
have a good laugh
it's sort of like a little
shock to the system,
and kind of turns
things around, and then
I just feel a lot better.
So that's in sum what we do.
And then this is a picture of--
that's Tim Cunningham, right?
DIANA: Mm-hmm.
LEAH: Yeah it is, on the bottom.
I don't know the
name of who's on top.
But this was just a
little girl, and what
we were doing Too Highs, is what
we call when you put someone
on your shoulders.
And I think kind of just
the expression and her body
language kind of shows at all.
But I think it
probably made her day.
And so now I'm going to show
just a series of pictures
of sort of a typical life.
What happens when we arrive at a
place to go give a performance.
So sometimes the kids have
been warned ahead of time,
like you're going to have
some performance or something,
sometimes not.
Sometimes we've
been there the year
before so they know it kind
of all depends depending
on the situation, if we've
been there before or not.
DIANA: Can I interrupt you?
LEAH: Yeah.
DIANA: Clowns exist
in every culture.
There's some kind
of jester or joker.
But we are definitely
a foreign idea
to these kids what we show up.
So when you enter, it helps to
partner with an organization
like Leah said, but also
the reaction we can get
can be anything from just
blank stares to what Leah's
about to show you.
So you never know
what you're going
to get when you show
up to a location.
LEAH: Sometimes grumpy, but
usually we turn that around.
That's happened.
OK, so here's an example of
more typical of what happens.
So these are kids in school.
They know something's
about to happen.
And then here they come.
And then they've arrived.
So more often than
not, actually,
what we're doing
is going like push
back we need space for a show.
But we're usually well
received when we go to places.
And I think well
recognized that like this
is kind of a time
for relaxation.
Especially in
places where people
are experiencing an
enormous amount of stress.
And this is a chance
to just let go and not
have to be in
charge, and not have
to like think about
whatever the stresses are.
What meal is coming next,
et cetera, et cetera.
DIANA: Sometimes people set
up ropes for this children
to stay behind.
And we're always
like no them come in.
But the teachers will set up
ropes and that kind of thing.
Sometimes they are corralled
but it doesn't always work.
LEAH: I've set up a rope
before, I'm not going to lie.
Whoa, it's too many kids.
Keep them back.
But it's such a joy
to be able to just--
this is kind of experiences for
me, been absolutely amazing.
But we have no limits.
We also Clown for UN workers.
So there's a picture
of some UN workers
that have put on
some clown noses.
And I've been to Haiti
a number of times,
and there's often
UN workers there.
So I wasn't there for
this exact moment,
but had a very similar
experience multiple times over.
So we try to leap over
different boundaries
sort of regardless
of what they are.
Basically we're like
we'll clown for anyone,
it doesn't really matter.
DIANA: So because we have
so many organizations
around the world, we're able
to get into, or be invited
to so many different places.
And we really try to choose
which country make sense
to be invited wear.
So Leah's going to
talk about a trip
that she did, but there
was a lot of conversation
about do we send US
clowns into certain areas?
Is it the safer to
send maybe Spanish
in certain areas because
of some political issues.
We try to go only
where we're invited.
So usually were working
with a partner organization.
This is an updated
list as of 2012.
We haven't updated it for 2013.
We're working on that right now.
But we've added to this list,
LEAH: A few places.
DIANA: Palestine.
Oh, no, it is on there.
So we've added to this list
a little bit this year,
and it continues to grow.
Unfortunately we're
always going to places
where there are crises,
and crises keep popping up.
Unfortunately it probably
will continue to grow,
but hopefully it will
shrink more and more.
LEAH: So, I guess
actually-- I want
to-- I don't know how to go
back to the previous slide.
Just touching on what Diana
said, and where we go.
We often partner with sister
or other organizations.
But sometimes we go on
trips that we don't.
And so we're allowed to go into
areas that the UN says, don't
go in there, it's too
dangerous and too scary.
And I don't know I guess because
our organizations basically
run by Clowns, except
for Diana, thank God.
That's why we keep her around,
to keep us on our toes.
And we're like, oh no one
else is allowed to go there?
Well, we'll go!
So I'll show some pictures
of that later and kind of
go into more depth.
But for me that's been sort
of really an awesome part
about working with
the organization,
to have truly no
limits set on that.
So sometimes there
are limits when
we're working with a
sister organization,
like we're kind of
under their umbrella.
So like, no.
No go there.
But often we're sort of just
allowed to go wherever we want,
we do that and
we're well received.
So this is just an example of
like we work with all ages.
But mostly we end up working
with the young and the curious.
And this is Yan.
And he and I used to do
service work together,
and we've not been on a
Clowns Without Borders trip
together yet.
But where is this?
DIANA: Indonesia.
LEAH: That's what
I was going to say.
This is in Indonesia.
This is like sort
of what I imagine,
or this has been my
similar experience.
After a show, kind of hanging
around afterwards and playing
with the kids one on
one, that kind of thing.
And this picture is
just to demonstrate
that we work with people
living in all different kinds
of conditions.
So sort of going off of what I
said earlier that whether it's
in a refugee camp or whether
it's just an area that's just
experience of an environmental
disaster or something like that
regardless of what it
is and where it is we
try to go there and bring
some levity to the situation.
So just to give
an idea, I'm going
to show you a bunch of pictures.
But the kind of places
that we perform,
hospitals, refugee camps, homes,
camps, hospitals, and prisons.
So here is a hospital
that, I think
this is probably in Haiti.
And we go into community
centers and churches,
and that kind of place.
This is a school setting.
I was on a trip to
Palestine earlier this year,
and we went to school that was
700 girls in a refugee camp.
And so kind of like just
a lot of kids, you know?
We got trampled afterwards.
But in a good way.
In a happy way.
Happy trampling.
If you can imagine such a thing.
There's such a thing
out there as getting
trampled in happiness.
And then this is an
example of a refugee camp.
And this is another
school performance.
And so something
else that we do is
we do workshops for kids and
also for their caregivers.
So I've done that work
in Haiti a few times.
So the last trip
I was on in Haiti,
we were working with
people with Haitians who
were working in their
community centers,
and so it was kind
of like a trade.
But we were also just
sort of like helping them
with games and
that kind of thing
that they could bring to
their community center.
And then they kind of used
us as like advertising.
So we would go to
their community center,
because they were having
trouble bringing in the kids who
are a little bit older
into the community center
because it wasn't cool.
But it turns out that
we're kind of cool.
So we went into the
community centers
and we would put
on this great show,
and then that would kind of
draw in some of the older kids.
Because in the music
centers they are safer,
and there is more
opportunity for reading,
and that kind of thing.
And whatever kind of work
that they kind of saw fit.
And so that was really great.
DIANA: In Haiti we're doing
a lot of work, especially.
We've been working
in Haiti since 2006,
so long before the earthquake.
But since the
earthquake, we've been
working with folks
who were displaced
from their original
professions and are now really,
what we're left with is
rebuilding their communities.
And so that's the
type of community work
that we're doing,
is teaching folks
who might have not ever
worked with children before
except for their own kids,
or whatever it may be.
And teaching and
giving them tools
to create community
and work with kids
in an educational setting.
LEAH: So this is those people.
So this, I think, this is
the trip before I went on.
But I know a bunch
of those folks,
so working with the same
people year after year
sometimes, as well.
So that's building
relationships,
and that's really
fun and rewarding.
So this is-- now these are
just a bunch of my pictures,
so just going to give
you a little bit.
And again, you can
interrupt me, it's OK.
I'm Jewish.
That's what we do in my house.
No?
OK.
Well.
I thought I read a book once
that said that how it goes.
OK, so this is Saida.
Saida, myself in the
middle, and David.
And this was somewhere
in Palestine.
I'm not exactly sure
where the photo was taken.
But that's why we're
here today, by the way.
Because I teach Stephen
trapeze, and silks,
and that kind of thing.
Or I try to.
I try my best to
try to teach him
how to hang from
things by his feet,
and elbows, and
that kind of thing.
And so I'd talk a lot of
class, or like whatever,
and so he thought, oh Yeah
let's bring them here.
So this is at a school, in
Palestine, the West Bank.
And this is like a kind of I
don't know, sort of-- there's
a few acts that we do,
I guess you could say,
that we do on a lot
of different trips.
And going back to what Alex
was saying in the beginning,
to this primal talk that
our shows are non verbal.
And so that's why
we're able to perform
in different parts of the world.
And so we call this copycat.
And basically like I'll bring
up the kid from the audience,
the other kid just kind of
snuck up because it looked fun.
We let him stay.
But the kid with
the clown nose on,
and I'll put a
clown nose on them.
And I'll just sort of
make some gestures,
and then the kid will follow.
And then I will do things
like I'll like kick him
in the butt, or
something like that,
and then when he kicks
me in the butt, which
is like no, because I'm
an adult, that's funny.
I don't know if you knew
that, but that's funny.
And so this is just them
sort of having a great time,
and their peers
love it, and it's
going to give them a
chance to be center stage,
and that kind of thing.
And this is probably one of
the most intense performances
that I've had.
This is in Martissant
in Haiti, and Diana
was on a trip that went
to the same location.
So to get to this location,
it was like a 30- 40
minute walk uphill with
places where people live.
DIANA: Through people's homes.
LEAH: Yeah, like kind of
through people's homes, and--
DIANA: Literally ducking
in doorways and windows.
LEAH: Yeah, kind
of going in and out
to get to this space
that had been created
probably like by some
other NGO long ago.
And we sort of got
like a little bit
of the sensation of
being the Pied Piper.
Because as we are walking
up, at first there
was like two or three kids,
and then there was more,
and then there was
many, many, many.
And people just kind of
stopped what they were doing,
and they were walking by.
You can see there's some women
in the back, who are probably
going from one place to another.
I remember this
performance there
was a guy who had
like just been bathing
and he was just like in his
towel, watching the show.
This is a rope situation.
We put that rope there.
And so I guess this is
just another example of how
we'll sort of like go anywhere.
So it took us a really
long time to get there.
We were carrying-- on
this one we did stiltings.
So we were like carrying all
this equipment on our backs,
and just trying to kind
of get to the location
where there was enough
open space to perform.
And then we just had a
couple hundred people,
you kind of see, they're
kind of gathered all around
to come watch the show.
So, you think I
should add to that?
So this was a kind of
average size performance
and then this was in
Palestine, a much smaller scale
performance, but still
larger than you guys.
But so this is just
the kids in that town.
And sometimes I guess being
perfectly honest, like oh boy,
like we have to do
this entire show
but there's like 15
kids or something.
But they end up loving it,
and having such a good time,
and laughing.
And I'll show pictures
of that in a second.
And this skit is
another sort of go
to-- not to say that--
but sometimes this
skit that I guess I've done on
a number of different trips,
and we call it dead or alive.
So in this skit my clown
character ends up dead.
And Saida is like
worried because she
thinks she killed
me, kind of thing.
And sometimes these
kind of issues
can be sort of really touchy
because a lot of these kids
have experienced a lot of
death, and the other issues
that we might bring up in our
clowning, but they love it.
And sometimes we question,
is that something
that we should try to bring up?
But I think it's something that
kind of needs that release.
Like they need to be able
to laugh at it in some way.
And so I don't know,
I was hesitant.
I'll say the first
time we did this,
are you sure this
is a great idea?
But it was, and I think it
kind of continues to be.
So--
DIANA: Yeah, we use it
a lot in South Africa
where we're dealing with HIV and
AIDS, and where there's so much
lost in the community
all the time.
And it just allows kids
who maybe haven't expressed
their feelings about death
to give some expression
because then they'll
start doing this skit.
A lot of times when
we leave the place we
hear back from the
educators that the kids copy
exactly what we do and then
they're doing it over and over
and making their friends laugh.
So it's a well thought out skit,
even though it's about death.
LEAH: Oops, so I
pressed the letter
b instead of the space bar.
Oh no.
There you go.
OK.
OK now who's that
smart pants one?
This guy.
OK.
So these are just some of those
kids from the slide before,
and again I guess from the
performers perspective,
you're like oh, there's only 5.
But then you see all
the kids laughing
and it immediately
becomes totally worth it.
And this is in Haiti,
this is like about a month
after the earthquake.
This is David again.
I've been on a few trips with
David, because I like David.
And the kids are
just super happy,
and just bringing smiles to
their faces is wonderful.
And we were also
really surprised
at how quickly we
were asked to come
to Haiti after the
earthquake, because there's
kind of the first
responders, and obviously
that takes priority,
and that's why
we wait until we're
asked to come.
But then there were
we had the experience
over and over and over again.
We were going to these kind
of makeshift hospital areas,
and a lot of the
doctors and nurses
who were there,
who had been there
since the earthquake or a few
days after, we saying this
is the first time
we've seen anyone smile
in a month and a half
or whatever it was.
And so I think that is why we're
asked often too come places.
So that's sort of
an acute situation.
But the example is just
that sometimes there
is that need to sort
of shake things up.
And I think that laughter
can be very healing,
and that's part of the healing
process and part of connecting.
And so going after
the earthquake
was definitely in an
intense experience,
but we were so well received.
And there was a
little girl who--
I guess she was found next
to her mom, who have passed.
And had sort of become
mute from the situation.
And we played with her, and
sort of got her to laugh,
and the nurses
like reported back
that then she started talking.
So OK, that's like
a beautiful story.
Doesn't always happen
that way, but I
think that it kind
of illustrates
that that's the kind of
thing that we can do just
through play.
And we have the time.
We go and sort of make time
for that sort of thing.
And so this is also soon
after that same trip.
And just working closely
with the doctors and nurses,
and we went often like from tent
to tent, or from sort of site
to site, and put on shows for
just like a handful of people
and sometimes for people
who had been waiting
for medical care
for a few weeks,
and just sort of camped out
waiting for medical care.
And those were bigger shows.
We had a show.
This is sort of an
awkward experience we had.
They were like oh there
is all this space.
That's fantastic.
Because sometimes
that's an issue,
especially after the earthquake.
There wasn't always space.
And so we found this space.
We're like, oh great, it's
some sort of hospital setting.
Fantastic.
So we like set up the
show, we're doing the show,
everything's going great,
and in the middle of the show
we hear like Doctor Chang
come here immediately!
And we're like what's going on?
And like someone's like rolled
through the middle of our show.
And we're like, Oh, we're in
front of the operating room.
That's why the space is clear.
But everyone was
like ha, ha, ha.
We were clearly back then
like oh no, we didn't know.
But it worked out.
OK, so this is from the most
recent trip to Palestine.
And for me, this is just about
how situations can be complex,
to say the least.
And this is in a refugee camp,
and these are not real guns,
these are toy guns.
But many of them have a
laser pointer on them.
And sometimes during the shows,
we'd be like, funny skit,
and they'd look down and be
like oh, a laser's on me.
That's uncomfortable.
So they just had
little like pellets.
You know?
So they're not entitled to kill.
So I tried to like collect
them before the show,
because I thought like I'll
just feel better about this,
and maybe I'll be funnier
if I'm not thinking
about this in the
back of my mind.
And I took this picture
just because I kind of
thought like this sort of
exemplifies what's happening.
But I mean it was
useless, because there
was like way more of them.
It was like the most fruitless
thing I've ever tried to do.
It was like give
me your gun, and we
don't speak the same
language, that thing.
Instead they'd be like,
BING, and I'd get shot.
But these are the kids
that those little play
guys belong to.
So they were having
a great time,
and then we gave them
their toys afterwards.
So I suppose we could go
into like what that means,
but I'll leave that for now.
And just say that what
was really important
is like having sort of the
connection and the laughter.
And just allowing
kids to be kids,
and allowing the space
for that to happen.
This is a picture of child
soldiers, right, in Sudan.
And so, this is just kids
being kids, having a good time.
And this is back in Palestine.
Some kids stole my
nose, I mean I let them.
And they were playing
with it, collecting water.
And then this is in Haiti.
And this is before
the earthquake.
And this was a kid who had
like a limp for something.
It's like an area
set up for boys only.
It's basically like
a big cement room.
But it was a place for
kids to go, for these boys
to go during the day.
And he was being made fun
of a little bit, I think,
just because he had
some physical ailments.
So we sort of pulled
him in and made
him the star of the show
for this little bit.
And afterwards, everyone was
like giving him high fives,
like Yeah!
So that was sort of
really nice experience.
David spins a ball in his finger
and gives it over to the kid.
And we went and so this
place is a really nice place,
that you didn't
have very-- I mean,
it was really just a
room in the outdoors.
But sort of enclosed from the
rest of the outside world,
I guess a little bit.
That's a nice safe space.
But unfortunately this place
was destroyed just right
after the earthquake which was
sad and hard to go back and see
that.
And that's all.
We're just here to tell
you that we need your help
kind of spreading awareness
about the organization.
And this is who we are!
Clowns Without Borders.
Do you guys have questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Is it just you see that more?
LEAH: I think it's like sort of
from just experiencing clowning
and performing, like you kind
of learn like who to go to.
And I mean, mistakes are
made, like that's the truth.
But I think that
sort of the more
that you do it, you
kind of figure out,
OK this is like a good choice.
I can see from their
facial expression,
and sort of from the
way they're reacting.
I mean, on our trips,
more often than not,
we have like
everyone wanting you
know, like kind of
the first things.
I want to be up there, too.
Like choose me, choose me.
But I think that's more
of our problem, which
I think is a good thing.
It's like we can't bring all the
kids up, but cest la vie, life
isn't fair.
But we do sometimes
a dance I've done,
that like it's kind
of a dance skit.
And we get like a
man and woman up.
So sort of like, we usually
get like the caretakers
of the kids.
And sometimes they're
a little resistant,
like they don't want to get
up in front of everyone.
But we like pull them up.
But then they always end
up having a good time.
I mean if someone I guess
if someone's resistant,
we just back off and
go to the next person.
DIANA: We often sometimes
will find out from a teacher.
A teacher will tell us, please
have that child to come up.
Or don't ask that
child to come up.
So especially in
places where we're
going back to where we
worked with them before.
LEAH: Yes!
More questions.
I like questions.
More interactive.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] some
situations just performing out
there to make sure you're
going to stay safe.
and whoever is
governing the area.
LEAH: Yeah!
Could I answer the first part.
One thing I'll say, like I
said like at the beginning,
I was like sometimes
people are a bit grumpy.
So I definitely
been in places where
there's like some of
the-- it seems to me
like some of the guys in
charge like, hey what's this,
you know?
But I'll say that like once
we get people laughing,
the mass majority just
seems to just like it
right in like those
various I mean usually it's
more received we were like, YAY.
But in those occasions,
when something like that
happens, once we kind
of get them laughing,
and we just connect
with them, I think
that those sort
of, I don't know,
limitations or those
tensions, just fall away.
They seem to just kind of go.
And everyone kind
of like relaxes.
And I think there's just
this general understanding,
we're just here to
have a good time,
and connect, and
make people laugh.
And then I think it doesn't
feel imposing so much,
as just sort of joining them
and an excuse for a good time.
DIANA: So to answer
the safety question.
We do put a lot of care
into the safety of things,
and some of the folks
who work with us
and who maybe aren't
the performer types,
have worked for like
Doctors Without Borders,
or we have a war
photographer who
does a lot of the photography
for some of the shows,
so we understand the precautions
that we have to take.
When we're going into a really
fragile area or a new area like
say Haiti right
after the earthquake.
So we worked in Haiti
through very kind
of informal connections
before the earthquake,
and then after the
earthquake, we now only
go there with a
strong connection
to an organization
that invites us.
And we get a safety
briefing before we go there.
We have curfews, we really
don't have much freedom
when we're traveling around.
It's not like we're going
to eat in a fine dining
hotel, or something like that.
But we're actually
usually home and really
exhausted and going to sleep
by 8 o'clock or 9 o'clock.
So we're usually not out after
dark and things like that.
If it's appropriate, were
escorted to a location.
The parading through
houses, that actually
was in Martissant,
and that happens often
and that's because that's what
we were told was going to work.
So we're asking local
people or people who
have been living in the
communities for a long time,
how do we promote
everyone to come to this?
Or where is the most
appropriate space to perform,
is another big one.
Sometimes, I've been
on a couple trips
where it's actually not safe
for our performers to perform.
So that's something
we always try
to have what we
call a logistician,
or somebody like me who doesn't
need to be up there performing
but is looking over the
clowns, making sure that their
hydrated, making sure
that they're wearing close
toed shoes, because a lot
of the places we perform in
have glass all over the
ground, and things like that.
So we take stock of
both the audience
and being aware
of how much we're
intruding on their
personal life,
but we also have to make sure
that the clowns are safe,
because they can't do
their work otherwise.
ALEX: I just wanted to add, I
think that's a great question.
And you do something willingly,
that you've done so many times
that you forgot to explain it.
And you break it down into all
these slices that you can use.
So what clowns do, and
what anyone can do,
is you go in there with
this joyful spirit,
and present a little tiny thing.
It could be just a little
gesture about a smile.
But you put yourself out there.
I even did it out there.
This was a little bit of Haiti.
I wouldn't call it a
crisis issues or anything.
But you're all trying to
make me go out at 12 o'clock
on a business day.
You all got us
working, you're right.
It's not easy.
But I didn't give up.
You just put a little bit out.
And the part that
Leah does, and I do,
and anyone that's
been doing it awhile,
is you pause after the
first three seconds.
Give a little
something, and then wait
to get the invitation.
And that's breaking it down.
That's news you can use.
That's what you can all do a
little more starting today.
Is you just put yourself
out there and then wait.
And respond to what happens,
instead of agenda, A, B, C,
D, I'm pretty sure when
you go into those places.
AUDIENCE: Yeah we take note
of what the atmosphere is.
So sometimes we show up
somewhere, there's a few folks
to tell a story
better than I do,
but sometimes we'll
show up to a hospital
and a child has
just passed away.
Or we'll finish the performance
and why we were performing,
a child has passed
away in the other room.
So we do rely on people
to give us the cues.
And we do a soft clowning,
we do about loud clowning.
So there are times when it's
appropriate to come out there
with stilts and
drums and trombones
and all these types of things.
And then there's
also times when it's
appropriate to do just very
quiet clowning and pulling
a handkerchief out
of somebody's ear.
You know, not even
making any sounds at all.
And that's more like the
hospital type setting.
And then the loud clowning is
more like the refugee camp,
where you have to make these
giant movements in order to get
to the 1,000th kid
a hundred rows back.
LEAH: I think sort
of like regardless
of what safety
precautions we do take.
Yes there's sort of
this inherent risk.
But I guess I've
always felt very--
I arrive feeling like
a little cautious,
but then I think like
one it once I get going,
you just kind of like just feel
what's going on in the room
or in the space, and
I always feel safe.
I have to say, I always
feel like Oh I don't know,
everyone's smiling at me!
What could go wrong?
So I mean
DIANA: It's a good
question, though.
LEAH: Yeah, I think it
is an important question.
And it definitely comes up, and
I think as we go into spaces,
were like especially
if unfamiliar to us,
we're like what's this?
And you just kind of have
to go with it, I think.
But I think also what Diana was
saying is really understanding
what's like appropriate
for the situation.
And that's a huge,
huge part of it.
And it's the same
thing, like knowing
who do you pull, or not
pull, or that kind of thing.
And I think that just
comes with the people that
are on the trip, and hoping
that you connect really
well with your
fellow performers,
and connecting all of the
people you're working with.
Steven, did you have a question?
Oh, behind Steven.
Steven, we're waiting for you.
Like a low priority.
AUDIENCE: So you imagine
every [INAUDIBLE] there's
a clown or gesture type of role?
Do you ever seek them
out or work with them
or do they come
and see your shows?
DIANA: Yeah, I think that
we try to do training
with adults who were interested.
So depending on what
our connections are
to that community, I think
one thing we try to find out
are like what what's funny.
What triggers funny
in that culture.
So it might be that gender
roles is a really funny thing
to play with because it's
such a regimented order
or something like that.
So we'll find somebody
in the community
to help us walk through that.
Like Leah said, we have
a lot of different pieces
that we do on a lot
of different trips.
So kind of our standard bits.
But every time a
group of performers
arrive in country,
the performance
gets tweaked with over
and over and over again.
And it's never the same.
LEAH: So like when the
last trip I went on
to Haiti, with the folks
that we are working with,
we put some of those people that
you saw one of those photos,
we put a show on
together with them.
And sort of the hope
was that they could then
put on their own
show after we left.
And so we would sort of improv,
and we created a show together.
And some of the scenes
that they came up with,
they were just like hysterical.
We wouldn't have thought of it.
Or we did stuff
around like sanitation
once in Haiti, and
just different things
in a kind of depending
on sort of what comes up.
So, yeah.
DIANA: The goal of
Clowns Without Borders
is definitely not to exist.
And for performers in
their own countries
to be able to be reaching
large amounts of children.
And for their to be no crisis.
Of course, so we wouldn't
need to be performing.
SPEAKER: We have time
for one more question.
LEAH: Stephen!
STEPHEN: I don't
have a question.
DIANA: He was saying
it was a time.
LEAH: OK, is there
any final last
like really short question?
AUDIENCE: Where do you teach
him to hang from his elbows?
LEAH: OK, so yes so maybe
I'll spend a minute.
So, I teach a aircraft
which is in Somerville.
So my day job is it trapeze
coach and aerials whatever
aerials, and also I'm about to
get my Master's in social work.
I'm going to start working
at Children's Hospital
in the clown care unit, so kind
of more the micro clowning.
Yeah you know, kids need
happiness here, too.
But a different
program, but also cool.
And so all the people
that we have on the trips
are all professional
performers in some capacity.
Some are performers
and something else.
But everyone is a
professional performer,
and they all
volunteer their time,
and we fund raise for
a lot of our own trips.
That's how they're
basically privately funded.
But I teach Stephen at aircraft.
He can hang by his elbow.
DIANA: She's a real clown.
LEAH: Yeah.
The real deal right here,
and a real aerialist.
Tonight I'll be
performing at the,
I don't remember
where it is, the arts.
And I don't know.
I'm going to do silks
for-- what is that called?
DIANA: Artists for Humanity?
LEAH: Yeah, that's the thing.
I'll be there tonight.
I was considering wearing
the weird gold costume
because it's James Bond themed.
It's a fundraiser for
the Boys And Girls Club,
and I was like maybe
I should just wear it.
And be like, I got to
go to gig afterwards.
But I didn't go there.
Kind of uncomfortable.
DIANA: Well, thanks everyone.
I mean we really hope
that you can spread
the word about
the type of clowns
that we are, and then type
of work that we're doing.
We think it's
important, that's why
we volunteer for
the organization.
Thank you.
LEAH: Thank you, Stephen.
DIANA: Thank you,
Stephen and Alex.